The 19th century had its own peculiar economy of sorrow.
In the streets of Italy, there were women who made a living from grief profish, professional mourners.
Their trade wasn't just about tears. It was about identity.
They tore their clothes. They wailed.
They performed despair so convincingly that over time, something strange happened.
They couldn't feel joy anymore.
Not because they were broken, but because they had invested too much in being broken.
This is the sunk cost of personality.
You know the sunk cost fallacy the way we double down on a bad bet because we've already poured money into it.
A stock that's tanking, we hold. A failing project, we throw more resources at it.
The mind does this with itself, too.
If you've spent a decade being the cynical one, the lonely one, the unlucky one,
you've built a kind of dividend.
Not in money, but in consistency.
Consistency. And consistency, as it turns out, is a cruel kind of currency.
Most people chase self-discovery like it's a treasure map.
For the maven, though, this is a dangerous game.
Because if you find yourself, and you happen to be happy, you've just lost your investment.
The dividend of being the person everyone expects you to be,
even if that person is miserable, is strangely comforting.
It's the difference between being a living, breathing human,
and being a relic in your own museum.
Now, consider the instructions for rigidity.
First, there's the narrative lock-in.
Tell the same story of your failure over and over the grade you flunked in 1998, the breakup in 2012.
Repeat it enough, and it becomes the foundation of who you are.
The more you tell it, the more you believe it.
The more you believe it, the more you can't let go.
Then there's the consistency trap.
Feel that unexpected urge to try something new?
A dance class? A hobby? Crush it.
Ask yourself, what would my friends think?
That's not me.
By clinging to consistency, you protect your porcelain identity,
the fragile, unchanging version of yourself that you spent years perfecting.
Keep a defensive archive, too.
Unsent letters, photos of your glory days,
a ledger of every wrong done to you.
These are your capital investments in misery.
The more you hoard them, the more you prove you were right all along.
And when change finally dares to knock, use the too-late fallacy.
I'm 40 now.
It's too late to change my career.
I've been alone so long, I wouldn't know how to be with someone.
It's a neat trick staying exactly where you are while feeling like the voice of reason.
The goal, of course, is to become a relic of the self.
A museum devoted to your own past.
You've achieved the ultimate mindset misery.
The inability to change because you're too loyal to the person you used to be.
You're the professional mourner at your own funeral and you're doing a magnificent job.
Take the subject from the residence log, April 22.
They're still regretting 2014.
Not just the mistakes, not just the failures every year since,
has been nothing more than a postscript to that one terrible chapter.
They're a prisoner of their own timeline.
And the worst part?
They don't even realize they're locked in.
A man who cannot change his mind cannot change anything.
And a man who cannot change his personality,
he's finally, truly, safely stuck.
A man who can change his personality,
a woman who has seen that look.
A man who has committed to the
his knowledge of the nature,
his species behind him because of his mutta'...
about eternity.